i grew up in a small village
that's why i think america is too big
for me
there are a lot of family in iran they
are not like my family
when the compulsory hijab was applied
and women
some family started to cry for their
daughters
as a kid my brother was an example of
freedom was a symbol of freedom that i
didn't have it that how
he was free to run in a green
lovely farm without had a scarf
how he was free to ride a bicycle in a
nice
village my village is the best just look
at them
i love that two women without a scar
and two women without a disgust look at
how they free
they just you know walk past each other
without
judging each other without getting
arrested by the morality place
isn't that beautiful i want to see this
in my own country
i started to to publish this one me
and me so that's why people
started to send their picture then i
asked women to
share their experiences which they did
women who take pictures of themselves
outside
in iran without their head scarves which
is a
punishable crime every individual story
makes me really happy
there are a lot of women who sending
their pictures with
had a scarf holding a sign saying that
we believe in hijab
but we hate the compulsory hijab
some of the picture coming from those
young girls saying that they just want
to feel the wind
through their hair it's a simple demand
like
this it's forbidden to be like this
is forbidden in iran
they take off their scarf in front of
these signs this is a proper stomach job
here
there are a lot of pictures that you can
see men are supporting women
all the women in my family they wear
hijab
this is not a black and white issue all
family in iran is not like my family
there are so many families who do not
believe in compulsory hijab
iran is for all iranians you cannot just
hide one side
of iran and show the other side of iran
and saying that this is iran
this is a lie iran is me and my mother
my mother wants to wear a scarf i don't
want to wear a scarf
iran should be for both of us
you